hi guys dr. Berg here listen I wanted to
do a video on high pulse rate because I
talked to this one lady on the phone and
she went to the doctor and they said
they ruled out heart problems from her
symptom of high pulse rate she has no
heart problems and they don't know
what's going on so I wanted totally I'd
create a video to show her all the
possible causes ok so a lot of times if
you're stuck with one thing we need to
kind of know all the potential things
that it could be number one you have to
realize that in average a normal pulse
rate of 72 but it could range between 60
and 80 or higher or a lot lower if you
are a really professional top athlete it
keep the pulse rate can go down to 35
sometimes even lower that's incredible
but I've seen people have a resting
pulse rate of 110 just like when they're
resting Bom Bom Bom now in a little
infant normal is 120 but as you get
older it should come down and what
creates a pulse rate is part of the
nervous system it's called the
parasympathetic nervous system that's in
the background that's literally
developing and pushing your pulse rate
down and an infant they haven't
developed that system strong enough to
keep the pulse rate in check so
everything is a little bit higher I know
my dog Charlie has a pulse rated
probably like 200 when he's at rest I
don't know that guy's that little guy is
hyper but here's some here's some causes
hyperthyroidism okay so the thyroid is
in hyper mode it's working too much
that can cause be a potential cause of
high pulse rate okay low potassium very
very common that the tascam is a
supports the parasympathetic nervous
system so it pushes the pulse rate down
many people that have high pulse rate
have really dis low potassium and that
would be a simple solution to fix that
medication so let's say your pulse rate
is high right after you got on certain
medication that could be causing it or
it could be a food allergy something
you're allergic to
epinephrine let's say you're an EpiPen
because you have allergies boom that
could be one of the causes or caffeine
you drink five pots of coffee a day you
know that's the obvious one or your
nicotine years chain-smoker well that
can increase the pulse rate and then the
heart problems it could be some
dysfunction in the heart itself or
adrenal issues adrenal controls a lot of
hormones related to the flight or flight
mechanism you can either increase
adrenaline the kids increased cortisol
it can deplete potassium a lot of things
these are just things to look at if
you're trying to get your pulse job
thanks for watching press it ok Jesus
let me do that over again
press the subscribe button press just
press this button right here subscribe
ok that one right there just do it right
now